betty muller maire de gaza sert et
conseillère départementale du canton
d'ensisheim le canton d'ensisheim qui
comporte donc 38 communes et qui est de
45 1534 habitant le canton d'ensisheim
commence par la commune d'arthenac donc
le plus au nord pour terminer avec les
communes d'ensisheim et rumersheim le
plus au sud à nous nous trouvons donc
ici à neuf-brisach dans la cité vauban
un des joyaux du canton d'ensisheim qui
est donc classée au patrimoine mondial
de l'unesco depuis 2008
neuf-brisach et ses remparts contribuent
sans nul doute à l'attractivité
touristique du territoire
donc ces visites de la ville et des
fortifications avec un lead qui est donc
en costumes d'époque et les visites un
peu plus ludique qui sont organisés pour
les enfants la recherche de trésors de
vauban et le musée du même nom
participent effectivement à et permet de
découvrir l'histoire passionnante de
neuf-brisach et ses richesses l'art et
la culture tiennent également une grande
place au coeur des remparts nous nous
trouvons donc ici devant la tour des
beaux-arts qui est un endroit donc une
d4 tour bastionnée
neuf brisach et qui accueille de
nombreuses expositions d'art mais
également des concerts de qualité
l'année dernière en 2016 dans le cadre
de la mise en valeur de ses
fortifications la commune de neuf
brisach atteint attirer plus de
touristes aussi a fait appel à des
artistes d'horizons différents il y
avait des sculpteurs des peintres pour
participer à un projet qui a été piloté
par les enseignants du collège de
volgelsheim donc deux classes de segpa
et des classes de d'ulysse de nombreux
élèves issus d'écoles primaires et de
collèges et des lycées se sont également
associés à ce projet de même qu'une
maison de retraite locale et en
établissement pour adultes handicapés
les particuliers et de nombreux
bénévoles ont également pris part et
plaisir à la mise en place de plusieurs
installations sur ces deux kilomètres et
demi de parcours de land art donc le
dard 2016 voilà donc effectivement connu
un véritable succès et de nombreux
touristes sont venus découvrir ce
parcours atypique pour 2017
un mini land art est en cours celui ci
sera réalisé uniquement par des
bénévoles
un très bel exemple de solidarité que
sont ces landes d'arte qui rencontrent
donc les participants les enfants les
artisans les professeurs les artistes et
l'ensemble de tous les bénévoles
un bénévolat que le conseil
départemental encourageons fortement par
son action bénévole à rsa alors nous
sommes qui circulent naïm à la maison de
retraite la roselière
cet ehpad est un établissement qui est
habilité à recevoir des personnes âgées
valides semi valides ou dépendantes
ainsi que des personnes atteintes de la
maladie d'alzheimer avec une population
de plus en plus vieillissante et le
souci d'un accompagnement
de qualité pour les personnes
dépendantes et en perte d'autonomie
nous sommes là au coeur même des
compétences du conseil départemental
le directeur de l'établissement monsieur
colère afin de faire de sa maison
d'accueil un endroit où il fait bon
vivre a lancé au mois de mars dernier la
première semaine citoyenne nepad et
s'agissait là de faire découvrir
l'intérieur de l'établissement
mais surtout le contribuer de manière
concrète au bien-être des résidents et
de favoriser la cohésion et les liens
sociaux
les bénévoles ont participé à la vie de
la maison de retraite à travers
différentes tâches le nettoyage de
vitres l'aide aux repas et l'entretien
des espaces verts entre autres cette
première semaine citoyenne a remporté un
vif succès et a permis de voir les rangs
des bénévoles se renforcer
l'intervention de ces bénévoles est
aussi un très bon moyen de réduire les
dépenses de l'établissement le conseil
départemental encourageons fortement le
bénévolat qui fait partie de l'adn
alsacien et qui apporte une vraie valeur
ajoutée à notre territoire et
institutions
là aussi nous sommes au coeur de la
compétence solidarité de la collectivité
départementale
et pour terminer je voudrais parler de
date du dernier investissement de
l'établissement qui a fait l'acquisition
d'une machine
à glace à l'italienne cet investissement
est à fait anodin car les glaces
présente de nombreux avantages
d'après les dires du docteur carmin de
l'établissement elles peuvent être
proposés à toutes les personnes même si
elles qui ont des problèmes de
déglutition
elles sont enrichis en protéines
rafraîchissent et donne oublier de boire
ce qui n'est pas anodin et ce qui est
don important à en période de fortes
chaleurs et saha qui aide à lutter
contre la déshydratation
un projet d'agrandissement est également
en cours et les travaux devront démarrer
bientôt
toujours dans le but d'améliorer le
cadre de vie des résidants de l'ehpad la
roselière à kunheim